Recall the Lemma that relates the number
of misses in an LRU cache to the number
in one with optimal replacement.
>From this Lemma there's
a corollary about regularity.
You can design an algorithm for an ideal
cache and if that analysis shows that
the number of misses is regular, then
an LRU cache will perform just as well.
So let's see how to use this.
Suppose you design a matrix
multiply algorithm,
assuming a conventional non stronsense
scheme and you do so for an ideal cache.
Let's say that your analysis shows your
algorithm does n cubed over L root z,
misses.
For this example let's further assume
that the line size is one word.
So will this algorithm perform well
on a machine with an LRU cache?
Let's check the regularity condition.
What happens when you
double the cash size?
Well, it introduces just
a small constant factor.
So the regularity
condition is satisfied.
And because Qopt is regular,
QLRU will be proportional to it.
By the Lemma, you could also evaluate
the right-hand side of this relation.
Here's what you get.
Basically an upper bound on
the number of LRU misses.
This brings us to one of
life's great pleasures,
well assuming you're a bit of a geek,
or is it nerd?
Let's just say enthusiast, shall we?
The pleasure is that
the Lemma is not hard to see.
For simplicity, let's assume that
the transfer size is one word.
Now imagine the sequence,
or trace, of all load and
store operations performed by a program.
Divide this trace into phases.
Let's define these
phases in a special way.
In particular, suppose that each phase
references exactly Z unique addresses.
Just to be clear, each phase might
contain many more than Z loads and
stores.
The phases might also have widely
varying numbers of loads and
stores as the illustration suggests, but
the number of unique addresses is
always exactly Z in each phase.
Now let's say the machine
has an LRU cache of size Z.
Think about what happens during
some phase, let's say phase i.
At the beginning of the phase,
it's possible that the cache is full.
So, the first time each unique
address of phase i is seen,
it could cause an eviction.
Thus, by the definition of a phase,
the number of cache misses
could be as high as z.
Now think about what happens on
a cache with optimal replacement, but
half the capacity, Z over 2.
Remember this optimal cache can gaze
into its crystal ball to see all future
accesses.
So during the previous phase i- 1,
what might the optimal
replacement policy have done?
Well it may have arranged itself so
that the first z/2 unique addresses seen
in phase i are exactly in cache,
that would mean no evictions.
But since the optimal cache is
only of size z/2, then it must,
at that point, start loading addresses.
In other words, the smaller but
all seeing cache has to perform
at least z over 2 transfers.
The competitiveness Lemma then
follows from these two facts.
One is at most Z and
twice the other is at least Z.